russia called the meeting to present
what it described as new evidence a u.s
supported biological research laboratory
in the ukraine posed a threat to the
region
put simply the ukrainian authorities
gave the pentagon carte blanche on the
territory of ukraine to carry out
dangerous biological experiments there
this is not the noble assistance to
ukraine that the american
representatives talk about this is a
cynical use of its territory and
population for dangerous research which
washington does not carry out on its own
territory so it doesn't run the risk of
hurting its own people
the u.s denies any chemical weapons
programs exist it is russia that has
long maintained a biological weapons
program in violation of international
law
it is russia
that has a well-documented history of
using chemical weapons
it is russia who is the aggressor here
the united states also warned that
russia may very well be planning its own
chemical weapons attack using a false
flag allegation to justify it it was the
second time in two weeks that the
security council met on the subject at
russia's request
the un's high representative for
disarmament said they had no evidence of
chemical or biological weapons but she
also conceded that the united nations
currently has neither the mandate
nor the technical or operational
capacity to investigate this invest
information i asked the united kingdom's
ambassador if that undermines their
argument if there is a genuine concern
the right thing to do would be to seal
off the site
have a ceasefire seal off the site and
then allow experts in to investigate
it is not the right thing to do to bring
spurious claims to the un security
council which are debunked by everyone
there
countries like china and brazil called
for just such an independent
investigation under the biological
weapons convention which prohibits their
use
meantime daily attacks continue to
batter ukraine many of them
indiscriminate according to the united
nations causing damage to civilian
infrastructure and mounting casualties
kristin salumi al jazeera the united
nations